I feel like you're trying to kill me
every night and I throw up
she's pure night before I came cuz I
don't want to get part of the Muslim
guys free Oh crazy me obviously no don't
be mean to her uh scary Island one of
the best moments in reality TV history
guys now imagine that moment but with
Real Housewives from all over the
country yes we are actually talking
about the possibility of a Real
Housewives all-star you guys this has
been a longtime dream of ours a dream
and Andy Cohen tells ET it will happen
one day you know what we will do Real
Housewives Allstars when the show is
just about out of gas so right now we
had our second highest season of Beverly
Hills New York highest ratings since
2012 Orange County last season as it had
its highest rated season in ten seasons
so we are nowhere near the point where
we need to put eight of them on an
island we will and I can't wait to do it
but it's gonna be at the end of the line
why don't you put them on a cruise ship
and you could do a crew that could do it
LoJack below it's about every every
iteration I've already thought of it and
we'll do it at the end it's something
that we don't want to waste now we want
to save it for like the end is anywhere
there's no one here Bryce Oh fine Andy
we'll just be here waiting patiently
with alcohol for that day now there is
only one way to end this guy's breathe
you